hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast insights into virus
replication the role of co-opt in host
proteins and lipids presented by dr.
Peter Nagi a professor in the Department
of Plant Pathology at University of
Kentucky I'm Suzy Valdez elaborate and
I'll be your moderator for today's
events we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth labyrinth is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located on the lower
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you are viewing this presentation
in a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button and let us know
you're having a problem good news this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing educational credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process for
obtaining your credits without further
ado please join me in welcoming dr.
Peter Nagi I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
everyone today I'm going to talk about
how viruses utilizes the cell how they
are using the cell resources to make lot
of new progenies and how the infection
goes on so I'm talking about irony
viruses these viruses have RNA genome
and so they don't have DNA but instead
they use RNA as their genetic material
and when they enter the cell shown here
then they can then unwind and this
unwinding after that the irony is
getting translated by the ribosomes the
host cell ribosomes interestingly the
newly made viral proteins which are not
many it's about two to four Hawaiian
proteins they will reorganize the cell
both the membrane structures and also
many pathways and as you can see here
RNA virus replication starts whether Ani
is copied into new progeny and this is a
very efficient process and one viral RNA
can produce as many as thousands new
progenies and after that the virus
builds this when they built it is an
application organelle then what happens
is that the virus will get encapsulated
and leave the cell and in fact new cells
or new new hosts and what is interesting
that all this process although it's very
robber robust it's very difficult to
study because it it is very
intrinsically connected to the cell lot
of processes will be changed so the
virus is during its replication cycle
has to build a very interesting
structure which is called the
replication organelle this replication
again I'm showing you this four
different viruses human viruses insect
viruses and plant viruses these
organelles are built from membranes by
the virus using host resources but as I
mentioned this is currently unknown how
what kind of proteins and lipids are
participating in this process so my
laboratory is involved in dissecting the
role of different viral and host
proteins how this process the
replication organelle formation is
conducted in the infected cells
the system what we are using is tombos
viruses these are very small plant
viruses is shown here is encapsulated
form the protein is outside and the
viral RNA is inside just one a single
RNA which is about five thousand
nucleotides so it's a very tiny irony
it's about two to three messenger RNA
lengths and it can code for five
proteins only so only five proteins and
I showing here two of them are the P 33
which is an RNA chaperone and P 92 which
is produced through a so-called
read-through mechanism where the
ribosome on five percent of cycles it
does not stop here to produce the piece
that you see but instead it slid through
and producing the larger P 92 which is
an aryl independent RNA polymerase this
is the the polymerase which makes RNA
copies and in one cycle these files can
produce as many as 1 million progeny per
cell and the other proteins are produced
later at during the infection which are
the coat protein which encapsulate
survival irony and end up cell to cell
movement protein and P 19 which is a
suppressor of RNA silencing which is
important to fight against the host so
it is important that these plant virus
is very similar to flavor viruses and
other human and animal viruses as well
so it can be used as a model system not
only for plant viruses but also for
other RNA viruses and this here I'm
showing you the structures what the
virus is building this is in
collaboration with the Christian Ares
collaboratory in Madrid so now this is
inside the cell you can see that this is
the yellow is the membrane of the host
cell and the blue ones is what
structures the virus is building these
are the so called replication vesicles
the viral RNA and the viral replication
enzyme is inside this blue
entities and the virus builds hundreds
of DS inside the cell and it's important
for us to understand how this is being
formed because then we might be able to
interfere the formation of these
structures and then we can fight against
the virus why these structures are
important is because they are allowing
the virus to sequester all the
components what it requires for
application a very small place which is
very good for efficient biochemistry
also this is a protecting entity where
the virus can hide from the hosts
recognition inside this blue entities
and also it might be able to avoid the
destruction by the host which because
the host has a lot of antiviral tools
rival appliances and proteases which can
destroy the virus
if the virus would stay unprotected
however within this small entity the
virus is protected from recognition and
destruction so you would like to
understand how this is being formed and
now this is shown here in that how many
of these are forming inside the cell
this is inside the cell is that the
peroxisome membrane and the virus is
facing a shown here the cytosol that is
small blue things facing the cytosol but
they have only a very narrow opening
called the next structure and you can
see here the gold ones are the ER
membrane structure so the calcium and
the ER forms a very close entity inside
the cells this is a driven by the viral
proteins to understand how the
structures form we have to perform
systems by the approach this is
basically to identify all the host
components which are participating in
virus replication and interestingly for
us we were able to develop yeast as a
system for us so instead of the plants
the first things what we are doing is
we are replicating the virus in East
this is a major technical breakthrough
for us that we were able to do this
because in yeast we can do much easier
and faster and cheaper genetic studies
so as you can see and the virus is
basically replicating inside the yeast
cells very efficiently as efficiently as
in the plant cells and so it's reaching
ribosomal RNA ligase it becomes the most
abundant RNA after 24 hours of
application so very robust process and
now using the system's barley my
laboratory studying both the Jeana
performing genomic screens where we
delete or study the libraries but the
yeast genes are deleted one by one and
we ask the question what happens to
virus replication also we performed a
proteomic screens to see interactions
between the viral proteins as well as
the host protein what those proteins are
interacting with the virus and finally
also performing lipid omec screens in
this situation when we want to
understand what's the role of the lipids
because the formation of these vesicle
like structures require lot of membrane
rearrangements which also will depend on
lipids so after performing orders
screens we want to identify those
factors which are provided so helping
the virus to take over the cell
migration of the cell functions and for
application we also identify factors
which are fighting the virus so they
would if they recognize the virus they
would destroy the virus this so-called
cell intrinsic restriction factors and
finally we also look at factors which
would affect the evolution of device
that the virus can change and the host
components can affect house how fast the
virus would change to adapt to a tool to
the cell after identification of all
these factors we want to understand our
functions the mekinese how these host
proteins interact with the wire
and of course the ultimate goal is to
obtain the antiviral approaches to to
make sure that the virus is that we can
fight against the virus so during our
process this is a summary at the current
statehood is that we perform many
genomic screens in yeast with deletion
libraries as well as temperature
sensitive libraries or overexpression
libraries and we also perform proteomic
screens with protein arrays and mass
spectrometry and so on to identify other
interactors inter viral protein or viral
RNA and again the lipid omics as well so
altogether we found 500 host genes at
least at this point which affect virus
replication so this is a large number
and we are studying several of them and
here is shown those which we already
characterized and published these are
including lipid biosynthesis genes
translation factors and so on and those
are here which are affecting negatively
the virus so they are fighting the virus
infection today I would like to in the
beginning I would I talk about kind of a
summary of our results and then showing
some new ones where I will go to more
details in a summary section I would
like first to talk about the recruitment
and pre-assembly of the viral
replication compartment or replication
or Ghana as shown here the the p90 to
align different RNA polymerase and the
piece of the protein
after that translation they would bind
to the viral RNA and they'll activate
the viral RNA into membranes and this
these are inside the cell these
membranes in this case it's the
peroxisome and the ER membrane which is
being involved and the wires also needs
replication proteins also recruit not
just the viral RNA but it starts
assembling host proteins so stolen these
are selected was protein stolen from the
host cell
these include translation factors
protein shopper owns and helicases
and so on so these proteins will
assemble together with the viral RNA the
endocytic replication and the other
thing what is happening is that to have
also the virus requires a lot of new
lipids new membranes and also using old
membrane or the existing membranes from
the cell so the virus will it's an
application proteins will form so called
membrane contracts sites where two
membranes comes together or very close
again this is all happening inside the
cell in this case one of the membrane is
the peroxisome membrane and the other is
the ER the endoplasmic reticulum
membrane this membranes come together
with the help of actin filaments and as
shown here schematically and you can see
the electron microscopic image so now
these two membranes are so close but
they are not they don't fumes so they
don't merge together they don't feel
they just stay together so close this is
so close that one single protein can
bridge the distance between the two
membranes and is allow the virus to
enrich membranes and proteins and the
target member in the peroxisome this is
important to make new membranes new
lipid composition for the replication
site so the virus can actively
manipulate the membrane structure and
for this device is using stable binding
proteins also so-called retro things
which are anchoring the virus
replication proteins at the ER membrane
and also actin filaments so but after
rearranging the membranes enriching
lipids and the memory contacts ice the
virus need to do further work and this
is to deform the membranes into this
vesicle like straw
which are very time in the size of these
about 70 nanometer so it's not visible
for for confocal microscopy only for the
ER so you can see here I'm showing an e
ER e electron microscopy image where you
can see the round shape in this round
shape structure the viral polymerase on
the other end depend on synthesizing the
viral RNA whose the minus strand RNA and
a lot of lot of new plus strands and
those are getting repaired through this
very tiny opening the next structure to
the cytosol to start new infection so
the virus is building hundreds and
thousands of these kind of structures
and my level two discovered to build
these kind of structures the virus is
recruiting of cellular factors so could
escort family this escort family is a
large group of proteins which can for
deform membranes into this kind of
structures so the virus is recruiting
these escort proteins to build these
nice compartments and hundreds of them
and when we deleted these yeast genes
now you can see that the structure is on
the left side is open the virus now
cannot form this closed semi closed
environment and when this happens now
the virus completely unprotected from
the cellular virus degrading enzymes so
the virus cannot replicate efficiently
anymore because it will get destroyed by
the host antiviral machinery so this is
very critical for virus replication here
now I summarize all the things which we
have discovered and published in the
last ten years from my laboratory so
first I talked about the recruitment
process when the virus is taking dozens
of host proteins in to the site or
application to form a pre complex the
simultaneous
the virus also rearranged membrane
lipids and enriched particle lipids at
the site of replication as shown here
using the membrane cont oxide strategy
and in addition to this the virus is
recruiting the escort proteins to build
this semi-closed replication environment
which protects the virus from
degradation host attack so what do all
these things I summarized but now I
would like to give some further details
and so for that I would like to
introduce the methods what is available
to us so in addition to of course of
course we do have the plant system where
we can study this is a plant virus so we
can study things in the plant cells as
well but in addition to that the new
systems what we developed I mentioned
first an assistant where the replication
is very efficient when we launch the
virus from plasmids we also have the
cell free extract system so in this
situation we rise the cell we destroy
the cell in a gentle way and then using
the cellular components we can rebuild
reconstitute the vile replicas complex
in vitro using recombinant and purified
viral proteins piece that is an 392 and
that will if we also provide the RNA can
make a complete cycle of replication
making both minors and plus trans lot of
new plus trans so this is something
similar to what happens to the inside
inside a cell but now it's in in vitro
environment cell free environment we
also contribute the virus application
compartment
using artificial lipid vesicles this
allows us to study the role of lipids
separately so first I would like to talk
about what kind of lipids the virus is
utilizing and how the virus is doing
again this is very critical for the
virus because it needs to build this
special environment this replication
organelle so what we found in yeast
cells as well in plant cells is that
this is a particle phospholipid labeled
here with blue is that the virus is
capable of hijacking or regulating this
lipid particularly B to the site of
replication the virus application is
this societies within the cell this
green circle and as you can see when we
test what is the it is phospholipid is
located is co-localize if you merge the
images you can see the colocalization of
this particular phospholipid with the
virus replication compartment this is a
nice-ass and the lower panel shows the
plant sir so you can get in the plant
cell you can see that a large portion of
the plant cell is taken over by the
virus and this area is also enriched
with this particular portfolio but how
this is being done is a very complex
process so my laboratory discovered that
the virus is obtaining these lipids and
membranes by hijacking the endosome
system the endosome is a transport
system inside the cell vesicle transport
system as you can see here is that from
a plasma membrane and also from the
golgi trans-golgi the early endosomes
forms and it's early endosome has many
protein sorting and lipid sorting
mechanism and it will also go to late
endosomes so it will either result in
recycling of components or it will fuse
to the vacuole what is called as
lysosome in mammalian cells for
degradation so what we found is that the
virus is converting this early endosome
machinery with the help of red v which
is as shown above here it's an answer
it's a protein which can activate
different pathways through binding to
GTP and bunny to effector proteins and
viral replication proteins bind to this
led v and recreating this to the site of
our application and again the major goal
for the virus is to build these
elaborate structures very large
structures using these extra lipids and
extra membranes to do so so the critical
enzyme for this what the virus is
hijackings the so called ETS 34 which is
a PI 3-kinase these kinase is and really
shown the structure of it you can see
the membranes and this is the protein
complex including the VPS 34 the kinase
and this is a lipid kind so it will
produce from phospholipid it's
phosphorylated and make it into a pi/3 p
this is important for end of cyclic
trafficking for so good autophagy and
also for trafficking lysosomal
trafficking and what we found is that
when this enzyme is deleted from yeast
this is now shown here so comparing to
the wild type situation where to East
has all the genes you can see very
robust application this is the northern
blood showing how much iron is
accumulating so you see that a lot of
iron is accumulating in a control
samples however when we deleted this
gene a VPS 34 now you can see that the
replication is very poor however when we
express from plasmid because the agenda
deletion is in a yeast chromosome but
now from the plasmid resupply the VPS 34
the white a con McConnell obtain even
higher level of replication when this
enzyme is abundant however when the
enzyme is a mutated form which does not
have the kind
activity anymore and we supply this
protein to to the to the system through
East now this cannot complement virus
replication of ours application is still
poor
so this enzymatic activity is required
for the virus and here I'm showing to
you that indeed the virus is very robust
been recruiting these protein to the
site of replication the blue shows the
confocal confocal image inside a cell
this is where the virus is replicating
you know aggregated peroxisome our
system and you can see the VPS 34
localization most of the VPS 34 is now
coloca lies
the peroxisome marker this is you can
aggregate focus on the virus is in using
the aggregation of and proliferation of
these structures you can see the very
nice colocalization although some VPS 34
still available to the SAS so not all
the proteins as to my the virus but a
significant portion of it this is also
shown the same in the plant cell not
just the previous one and as you can see
that this interactions the replication
protein will now clockwise with direct 5
again this is the endosomal protein what
the virus targets and you can see also
the lipid which is being made by the
kinase these are all co-localize inside
the cells so basically the virus is
stealing away this system the and this
lipid from the Sun and when we delete
this red fire protein similar to the
kinase protein now this is basically
three different genes in yeast and it's
all wrapped 5 proteins but when we
delete all three of them now what we can
see that the virus replication is very
poor inside and it says
for this we use this tomato Bastogne
as I mentioned earlier this is a
paroxysm replicating virus fortunately
for us we have another trembles virus
which is carnation Italian ringspot
virus which is using a different in soft
several organic so called mitochondria
so this allows us to study virus
application different environments of
cellular environment inside the cell so
when we have these second two moose
virus the mitochondria are replicating
wires you can also see the deletion of
de slap five genes cause major problem
for virus replication so depend not
depending on where the virus replicates
now the virus has to recruit these wrap
five proteins and VPS 34 kinase to build
its replication organelle and this is
also shown here with the peroxisomes
you can see the the enrichment of
phospholipid and rat 5 and the virus
replication proteins all these together
inside the cleanser in this situation it
is the peroxisome membrane and for the
second two moose virus it is the
mitochondrial membrane so the virus is
very efficiently taking these taking
away these components from the cell for
its own purpose and when we delete this
lab 5 from the cell now the virus cannot
steal the phospholipids anymore so you
can see the localization of the
phospholipids which is enrichment in a
white at least the virus is replicating
however one these lab 5 genes are
deleted now the phospholipids are not
imaged and the site and the virus would
like to replicate and the replication is
very poor so in summary in this first
part you can see that the virus is
taking away
and a solar system with the help of rf5
to record Twitter the peroxisome or from
the virus to the mitochondria inside the
cell and to build this large replication
organelles which is very unique to these
RNA viruses another very interesting
process which we are studying currently
is that what how the virus obtained
energy to support virus application all
this process not very robust happening
in 16 to 24 hours the aware genetic
changes inside the cell how the virus
finds energy to to do this is what my
level 2 discovered with the help of
those screen screams I mentioned earlier
our laboratory discovered that the virus
is also hijacking Draca lytic enzymes
it's girl aquatic enzymes inside the
cell a very ancient process it's big
it's based on utilizing glucose which is
the major energy source for many cell
types so this glucose the sugar is being
converted to pyruvate inside the cytosol
of the of the cell to obtain different
compounds chemical compounds as well as
importantly ATP there are two steps you
can see in the beat pgk one produces
from ADP ATP which is a very high energy
containing molecule and also the
pyruvate kinase and which is CDs uniting
in yeast the Sydney also producing from
ADP ATP this is basically energy
currency inside a cell that this ATP's
can be used for many processes they are
fueling lot of process by providing
energy and what we found is that the
virus is very efficiently hijacking this
ATP producing ends
from the south so here is the kjk when
we go Express we purified the virus
replication components the entire
complex from the cell and we look at it
what other proteins are Co purified with
this complex and this Western law shows
that the pre JK one is ATP producing
enzyme is very efficiently purified with
the virus replicates complex so the
virus is taking the Vedas from the cell
it's also shown here in confocal images
you can see the device application
compartment and the printer k1 is very
nicely co-localize not all but many of
the PG key enzymes are now part of the
replication compartment when the virus
is not present you can see that PG key
is distributed in the whole cytosol
similar things happening in rhesus with
the second ATP generating hands and
pyruvate kinase now this is Co localized
with the virus replication compartment
during infection so this shows that the
virus is very efficiently hijacking the
enzymes and when we study this in vitro
in the cell for extract we can
demonstrate that indeed this is directly
happening so now we are sending the
virus replication complex in vitro using
East cell free extract so the origin is
does not have any viral components we
provided purified components from
bacteria where we propagate them in
bacteria and as you can see when the
user yeast mutant when we can down
regulate expression of PG k1 now whilst
replication is very poor when p g k1 is
present in a very low amount so this is
a direct evidence that PG k1 is very
important for various application
similarly when we study the role of the
second ATP generating enzyme the
pyruvate kinase and now we are using
temperature-sensitive mutant in yeast so
when we elevate the temperature Nunis
growth this enzyme is partially
inactivated you can see that virus
replication is in big trouble so the
virus probably cannot obtain enough ATP
who its replication and also this is
shown in in plant cells that the virus
is very actively taking away the
pyruvate kinase from the cell to the
site of replication and when we implants
to confirm the data what we obtain the
means when we down regulate is silenced
expression of these proteins now you can
see that the plant is very healthy you
can I mean from not being infected by
the virus you can see here that we
cannot easily detect the virus
replication in the white-eyed plants in
these plants now the device is very
actively replicating as you can see here
with no damn block very high level over
application and the plants will be
killed very shortly as you can see here
the dying plants but again when we don't
regulate this ATP generating enzymes now
the virus cannot do the same to the
plaintiff cannot replicate to high level
at all to demonstrate directly that
indeed the virus is utilizing this for
ATP generation we adopted a system where
we can detect ATP generation in this
situation there is a bacterial protein
subunit which has two conformation in
one conformation it has this extended
structure and another confirmation has
this compact structure so now
technically we are using a system where
we have two fluorescent proteins these
two fluorescent proteins can make called
focal microscopy we can't
the excitation state so when it's ATP
free situation and low level of ATP
around then this subunit of this ATP
binding solids in this extended form in
this situation when we use light to
illuminate only the CFT now this cannot
pass the energy light to Venus the
yellow fluorescent protein so in this
situation now when we detect the yellow
excitations we find very low signals
rather than ATP bound form in the
situation of there's a rearrangement of
this protein which binds the ATP and now
this brings very close vicinity these
two proteins and so if we excite with
laser the CFP this can easily pass past
energy to the Venus so when we detect
using this light channel we can detect
now this fluorescence and this is called
fret so what we have done we connect
these so called ATP sensor we connected
with the virus replication protein we
fuse them together so now we measure
what's happening in the vicinity of the
viral polymerase utilizing this system
now what I would like to show it here is
different images in these cells is that
where the Weisse application protein is
that this is the scale here so when it's
very intense whitish and and red now you
can see that the flat signal is very
high so now it means that it's an ATP
bound form so there is a huge amount of
ATP being produced the other side of our
application the vicinity of the viral
colonies now when we use the mutant
enzyme is the temperature sensitive
pyruvate kinase in the yeast and this is
the only copy available for you
and use higher temperature now you can
see that the signal is shifting towards
the blue which would mean that
now the Apollinaris ATP core environment
there is not much ATP around so this
suggests that indeed hijacking of the
pyruvate kinase and this ATP generating
ends up from the glycolysis is important
for the virus to enrich to obtain ATP at
the site of replication and now I'm
going to show you time course
experiments to show that they need this
ATP is being utilized by the virus so
this is a very early for our time point
off to express the viral proteins and
now this more application is now this is
the pre assembly process and as you can
see now the ATP sensor is measuring very
high ATP levels in the yeast cells
around the viral polymerase at the 8
hour time point when replication starts
very intensively to produce viral RNA
progeny now you can see that the signal
is getting more bluish meaning that the
ATP is now used getting used up by the
wires and by the 12 hours and
replication is real in terms you can see
now the signal is the ATP signal is now
very bluish so the virus is intensively
using of the ATP generated by these
glycolytic enzymes it's the same is
happening in a plant cells so when we
express this components viral components
during infection in the plant cells you
can see also that here very high threat
signals can you see on the right image
so the virus not only needs but also in
plant cells doing the same thing
and biochemically to show you why this
is important for the virus this is a
biochemical assay the virus replication
produce
you double strain iron it so original
device is single-stranded in the plus
trend and the polymerase would make it
into a double strand RNA and this CC
Dunedin has to be unwind to obtain
structures which is the polymerase can
utilize so here we artificially make a
probe which will hybridize it's
reductive probe hybridized portion of
the viral RNA and then we provide
enzymes which the virus stealing from
the cell these enzymes are against the
silly cases can unwind the structure of
this double strand RNA structure so you
can see the double strand RNA moves into
the gel act days but when we provide the
pyruvate kinase together with its
substrate now it provides ATP enough
which divided this leakage host proteins
can use to unwind and obtain single
strand RNA which is suitable for virus
replication this is just one example we
do other essays to demonstrate why the
recruitment of the ATP generating
enzymes so important for the virus and
this is summarized here
and so lot of steps from the pre
assembly of the all these most proteins
and also the replication as I showed you
any cases all this requires ATP so the
virus is hijacking this ATP generating
enzymes to provide ATP locally and
basically using the host cell energy
system to obtain energy for its own
replication so these are the different
steps and the different enzymes involved
in summary so to summarize our
presentation my presentation today the
wires the tomato bush histones wire
squats
conserve cellular factors these factors
are also hijacked by other viruses
although the details rose
No but what we are really happy to see
is that our wire skills utilizing these
conserved factors also used by the cell
and also by other viruses during their
infection and so these include different
translation factors stress components
also involves glycolytic enzymes to
generate energy
it also endosomal compartment as i
previously mentioned from kind lipid
kinase to red flag regulating proteins
and also directing cytoskeleton over
these are the viruses hijacking to build
these elaborate structures to support
application very robust and application
and again our ultimate goal is to
interfere with these processes to help
us survive infection however there are
critical still critical questions
unanswered for example what co-opted
host factors are stolen by the virus
only for short period of times and which
are those which are permanent is staying
inside replicates complex those would be
primary targets for antiviral approaches
and also what are those factors which
serves as assembly hubs currently our
thinking is that the virus is not
recruiting all the components one by one
by one but it will regulate many things
through complexes already pre existing
cellular complexes to make the process
faster finally I would like to thank all
my collaborators and PhD students and
and postdocs during the work including
Johnny Pagani who developed a system for
cell-free studies and today's panelist
who developed the inst system and Kaiser
who developed the cell-free the liposome
based replication system
as well as Ching hai Chuang for the
glycolytic and also I would like to send
your funding agencies the National
Science Foundation and NIH for their
funding and especially the collaboration
with Cristina risco with the structures
of the viral replication compartments
and with Andy white who collaborated us
on the role of the RNA and protein
interactions during replication and I
think thank you for listening to
presentation and I'm ready to take
questions thank you thank you dr. Minami
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
type in those questions in the box that
appear on your screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started we have a great audience
today our first question is why do
viruses need to induce membrane
proliferation and deformation during
infractions so the virus basically the
virus basically has accomplished two
major roles by this the first one is to
build its replication compartment very
sequester collects all the host proteins
and all the factors required for
application this is important for
biochemistry that it it will make
everything very robust by put collecting
them into a smaller environment
and the second one is that the virus is
it's easy to recognize the invading
virus because it's so robustly
replicating so the Xhosa can launch
antiviral response to destroy the virus
this is a built-in mechanism in Xhosa so
the virus is building these cellular
compartments based based protected by
these ligands these lipid membranes is
basically to hide away from the
recognition by the Xhosa so the host
cell will not easily recognize that it's
being utilized by the virus because the
virus is hiding in these compartments
pretending that it's look like like a
cellular membrane structure thank you I
made to take thanks thank you dr. Nagi
our second question from an audience
member is what is the advantage to be an
RNA virus versus a DNA virus so
different genomes DNA genome versus RNA
genome is a very interesting question
and based on studies it looks like the
advantage of the irony versus a very
common and they are the most abundant in
eukaryotic cells versus the bacterial
cells the prokaryotic cells the Irani
versus probably has advantage because
they can very quickly replicate in the
cytosol so DNA most DNA viruses we need
to enter the nucleus so they have to go
through not only the outside membrane
there the plasma membrane which protects
the cell from the outside environment
viruses need to enter and go through
these this protective membrane so the
only vices only have to go is the most
of them only have to go through this
outside the plasma membrane and then
they can write to be start replication
of their RNA genome so it's very fast
and relatively easy process DNA viruses
on the other hand they have to not only
go through and most of the DNA of ice
not only have to go through the plasma
membrane but they also have to enter the
nucleus DNA replication occurs inside
the cell this is the natural the cell
replication and so it requires basically
going through multiple membranes and
utilizing the cellular DNA synthesizing
machinery and this is a lower challenge
for DNA viruses so they are replicating
usually much slower than RNA viruses so
eukaryotes probably favor the RNA
viruses are more common because they are
just faster more evolved or the kinetic
cells and DNA viruses thank you thank
you dr. Nagi and thank you for our very
engaged audience today we have quite a
few questions coming in and have time
for a couple more how much cell damage
is caused by the virus infection so
virus is to build a so many progenies
and to rearrange membranes and world all
these processes it can make a lot of
damages to the south so it really
depends on how much particle virus is
adopted to that host cell most of the
time when the virus is very well adapted
to the cell the damage caused my means
not enough to kill the cell so the virus
can again when it's dead updation is
very good between the virus and the host
and both can work together or at least
coexist however when the adaptation is
not as good from the host side or the
virus side and many times the virus can
cause so many damage than dissolve in
the kill so in different environments
different interactions it will be
decided different host different viruses
have different reactions which can go
from very severe little damage to a
little bit less damages as well so lot
of different responses can happen thank
you I'm ready to take next question
thank you dr. Maggie and we have time
for one more question
today our last audience question is can
other viruses replicate in yeast
interesting question thank you
yeast is a very good host system because
unlike other eukaryotes especially
plants or developed million systems the
gene redundancy is very high and very
high number of genes these eukaryotes
have so yeast is much simpler system so
you can study in East things much faster
easier and much cheaper than in other
eukaryotic cells so East is an excellent
model system however this is a major
challenge how yeast can be utilize
developed for wireless research so
currently the number of viruses which
can be replicated in East is growing in
addition to the thomas wires represented
today there's also originally developed
by baracus laboratory is the for mosaic
virus which is another plant virus and
also an insect virus which no the
viruses which can replicate in ease but
now the numbers are growing and one of
my former postdocs developed a DNA virus
replication system in yeast so the
numbers growing but it's still a little
bit low but it's a major advantage but
it's important that after we discover
synchronise you have to go back to the
original client system to confirm those
findings thank you
[Music]
I finished my answering today thank you
thank you dr. Ron he's so much for your
wonderful answers do you have any
closing remarks you'd like to share with
the audience before we close our webinar
today so I really enjoyed this
possibility I enjoyed this opportunity
to talk about viruses are and wireless
interactions is today is the most
exciting area of research because in
addition of course that viruses are very
dangerous
plant and animal and human pathogens
they can cause a lot of harm to human
health as well as of course in
agriculture they do a lot of damages so
it's important for us to understand and
protect ourselves and our environment
from viruses but but the interaction
between viruses and the hosts is much
more complex there are examples where
viruses have positive effects on
different systems there are also cases
when we utilize viruses to you know in
medicine and to obtain ways of killing
in pathogenic bacteria or utilizing them
for curing different diseases including
cancer and why is also important through
their interactions is to understand what
caused disease in different organism
viruses are easier to use as
intracellular pathogens to to understand
what is the disease and what is has poor
Assad and for an organism and also they
through the pathogenic process the
interaction process we can understand
functions of the cell proteins so
different cellular functions you can
develop new ways or not only for
Diagnostics but also for curing
different diseases with with chemicals
so
these are all things which the virus
host interaction studies can help us so
I'm very excited about continuing this
research and many of my colleagues share
this region as well thank you so much
dr. mani thank you so much for your
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to thank our
audience members and especially
elaborates for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you'll receive an email from labyrinth
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
we hope to see you again bye-bye